VERSATILE IS KEY.
LAST
NIGHT.O THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE,
THAT IS
>> Randy: THE PANTHERS POWER
PLAY
TONIGHT, A PANTHERS HAVE POINTS
HERE IN THE FIRST.FIGHT
THROUGH.
TO THE MIDDLE, THOUGH, TAKES
THE SHOT WIDE.
AND OF THE SHIFT, FOR BA HIT PA
BEFORE THEY
ON THE LEADERBOARD.ndy: WE JUST
HOW DANGEROUS HE CAN BE.
HE PUT HIMSELF, RIGHT IN THE
SECOND PERIOD.  WAS THERE.
CAME ON THE ICE WE GOT THE PLAY
DEFENSIVELY.WARDED WITH A GOAL.
HE JUST GOES RIGHT TO THE
FRONT OF THE GOAL,DEPTH OF HIS
TEAM.
THEY HAVE SEEN IT, TALKED ABOUT
GETS CHECKED.
BUT HENMAN HOLDS IT IN.
COMING INTO THIS GAME,
>> St
>> Randy: PANTHERS COME RIGHT
BACKIS PLAYING
WITH
>> Randy: WHAT A PASS BY
HUBERDEAU. THAT.
>> Steve: WHY DO YOU THE LIGHTN
WERE TRYING TO DO, HERE.